stephen king is quite prolific having
written countless novels and
short stories many have been adapted
into movies or tv shows and there is
plenty more to come
these are all the upcoming stephen king
movies and tv shows that fans can
anticipate coming down the pipeline
stephen king has said before that
lisey's story is one of his favorites of
his own novels
the story hits close to home for him he
told indiewire
it's a story about love and marriage and
the creative impulse now he's had a hand
in its adaptation writing every episode
of the limited run series
he calls it his passion project so by
default we're more interested than ever
felicia's story stars julianne moore as
lisi landon widow of famous author scott
landon who is played by clive owen
she has to grapple with tense real-life
horror that resurrects
all the buried memories of their
marriage that being said
filling in the gaps of their love story
might save her life
the result is what director pablo
lorraine calls quote a romantic
suspense thriller with fantasy elements
which should ring true for fans of the
book
lisey's story starts airing on apple tv
plus in summer
2021 like hulu's castle rock
epic's chapel weight is a stephen king
tv series that
isn't exactly an adaptation instead it's
a prequel to his famous vampire novel
salem's lot the series promises an
unusual and exciting notion
1850s stephen king a lavish blend of
history
and gothic terror adrian brody stars as
captain charles boone
a widower who returns to his family home
in preachers corners main where he meets
rebecca morgan played by emily hampshire
an ambitious young author who hopes that
serving as the boone's governess will
give her plenty of writing material
we're sure it will especially since
charles and rebecca are due to come face
to face with mysteries and horrors that
tie into their family's histories
pet cemetery stephen king's harrowing
novel of what happens when
sometimes dead is better has already had
two big screen adaptations and soon
streaming service paramount plus will
offer fans a prequel lorenzo dibon of
ventura
and jeff bueller the producer and writer
of the 2019 adaptation will have a hand
in shaping the new story
according to them it's supposed to be an
origin story so
this may wind up being along the same
lines as the salem's lot prequel
chapelweight
the upcoming firestarter remake directed
by keith thomas
is all set to cover new territory thomas
spoke to cinema blend but his
appreciation of the original 1984
adaptation
its fidelity frees him to work on a
remake that explores the book's themes
without sticking so strictly to the text
he said that while he's making changes
he thinks the results will explore
a lot quote that king obviously is
hinting at throughout the book
with a new direction that's inventive
but still deeply involved with the
original novel
the fire starter remake is off to a good
start
stephen king's novella the gingerbread
girl is a tight
grueling and suspenseful story about a
grieving woman whose running route leads
her into the path of a killer
it has all the ingredients of a good
movie which is why we're excited one is
now in the works
the film will reunite king and craig r
baxley who already has a number of king
productions under his belt including the
storm of the century
rose red and kingdom hospital the two
are set to collaborate on a screenplay
and then baxley will settle into the
director's chair
sleeping beauties is a 2017 novel
co-written by stephen king and his son
owen king featuring an eerie premise
where women begin suffering from a
condition where they fall into a deep
cocooned
sleep that takes their unconscious mind
somewhere else completely
amc is hoping to put together an
open-ended series and the network has
already ordered a pilot scripted by owen
king
full series pickup will probably follow
soon
mile 81 has a concept that will probably
be familiar even to casual stephen king
fans
the evil car the story's premise is
diabolically simple
drivers see what they think is a
stranded automobile
an ordinary station wagon and stop to
help out the driver
very very bad idea its film adaptation
is in the hands of horror director
alistair legron the officially released
summary doesn't
mention a car which may mean the story
is due to be tweaked a bit
either way we know we're looking at a
movie about strangers at a rest stop in
particular
a heroic kid named pete banding together
to face down a dangerous mystery
and that sounds pretty good even if we
don't get another evil car out of it
hey we'll always have christine stephen
king's the dark half is a story of what
happens when a writer kills off his pen
name
only to find that identity taking on a
murderous life of its
own it was adapted back in 1993 but
mostly fell flat to the box office
now the novel is finding new life in
unexpected hands
alex ross perry perry's previous movies
have included the
emotionally raw her smell and the darkly
comedic
listen up phillip a great director but a
surprising choice
that being said perry's involvement has
our interest peaked
even if he's not an obvious match for a
stephen king story
he has a knack for portraying complex
emotions and getting fantastic
performances from his actors
both of which should come in especially
handy for tackling the psychological
horror and identity issues of
the dark half the tommyknockers is a
stephen king novel that
even king has gone so far as to call
quote
an awful book but it's also a powerful
story with
a lot of hard-hitting themes and it's
clearly a book executive producer larry
sinicki is hooked on
in 1993 he helped produce the
mini-series and now he's serving as
executive producer for the upcoming film
sinitsky still believes in the story
wholeheartedly the hollywood reporter
quoted part of his mission statement
it's an allegorical tale of addiction
the threat of nuclear power
the danger of mass hysteria and the
absurdity of technical evolution run
amok
topics as relevant today as the day the
novel was written
it is also a tale about the eternal
power of love and
the grace of redemption it's a strong
pitch and it's attracted
some impressive talent horror veterans
james wan
and roy lee are producing and they've
brought on screenwriter jeremy slater
the creator of the gone too soon tv
version of the exorcist
they all know horror and lee even has
two previous king productions under his
belt
slater knows how to script adaptations
that show love for their sources but
still move in new directions
that might be exactly the right recipe
for adapting a book that's controversial
even with its author fans have waited a
long time for an adaptation of the
talisman
the inventive dark fantasy novel
co-written by stephen king and peter
stroud
now it's finally happening it's had a
bumpy road in its progress towards the
big screen
it started out as a planned tv
adaptation then it became a movie that
was going to be written and directed by
josh boone
the mastermind of 2020s the stand
miniseries now
it is set to become a netflix series
helmed by the duffer brothers
the creators of stranger things it's a
great
moment for steven spielberg who loved
the book so much that he got universal
to buy the rights for all time
so he'd always be able to have a hand in
bringing it to life
on working with king he told
entertainment weekly
it's something that i've wanted to see
come to theaters for the last
35 years i feel that in the very near
future
that's going to be our richest
collaboration
we love the geeky thrill of two of our
pop culture favorites colliding a
stephen king book getting an edgar
wright adaptation
pretty much feels like a dream come true
it bridges a horror geek
generation gap bringing one of the best
and funniest genre directors recent
years
into collaboration with the veteran king
of horror the best of both worlds for
reimagining of the running man
plus this remake offers book fans a
chance to forget about the notoriously
unfaithful 1987 adaptation starring
arnold schwarzenegger
wright's already promised that he'll
stick closer to the original story
he has a deft hand with both satire and
gory violence so we're sure
that the running man can finally get the
brutal
darkly comedic cat and mouse adaptation
it deserves
in the family of stephen king
adaptations shutter's creep show series
is something like a cousin
it's the offspring of the gleefully
lurid creepshow movie which was a
collaboration between stephen king
and george romero it borrows the movie's
framework which features the titular
creep
introducing each episode's standalone
tale via the creepshow comic book but
most of its stories don't originate with
king regardless it's still part of the
family
we're always delighted to see it and
2021 will see a fresh batch of fun
spooky episodes shutter has announced a
handful of planned storylines all of
which
sound promising keith david starring in
a possible deal with the devil drama
that also
involves an exterminator sign us up
the institute may not qualify as a
classic stephen king novel in terms of
when it was published but it's still
about as
kenyan a novel as you can get kids with
special powers
sinister government agencies horror
friendship
maine and more it's fresh and new and
capable of delivering a powerful hit of
nostalgia
so it's not a surprise that someone
bought the rights immediately
a limited tv series is now in the works
with david e kelly
and jack bender working on development
this isn't their first king adaptation
they both worked on the mr mercedes tv
series something which
clearly revved them up to return to
stephen king's playground
and stephen king is a master riding what
scares us what's under our bed
so to speak some pending stephen king
adaptations have us
excited some have us intrigued and at
least
one leaves us completely baffled we say
this because
cujo king's classic novel of a good dog
gone rabbid
has now become c-u-j-o which apparently
stands for
k-9 unit joint operations huh
whatever it is it's a far cry from the
ordinary horror of a mother and son
trapped in a hot car
and menaced by a prowling dog the remake
might be taking on a science fictional
spin or maybe
some kind of canine angle all we know is
that it's set to start dj perry
and be directed by lang elliott whose
filmmaking career has been on pause
for years needless to say we can't help
but wonder how his take will differ from
the original
the shining is one of stephen king's
scariest novels
and it led to one of the best horror
movies of all time
come play with us and like the guests of
the haunted overlook hotel
the story won't stay dead and fans don't
want it to
king followed up on danny torrance's
adult life with the sequel dr
sleep which got an underrated adaptation
helped by director mike flanagan
now the shining has come back to us
again this time in the form of the
proposed hbo max series
overlook the official announcement was
pretty bare bones but the title suggests
that we might be ditching the torrance
family and
focusing on the hotel itself the
original novel hints at a long history
of atrocities and horrors so it's ripe
with potential
for a terrifying and sprawling prequel
series
whatever happens we can all relish the
anticipation of the terrors to come
the jaunt is a short story that starts
off as science fiction but
ends as one of stephen king's most
terrifying works
and it has a real doozy of an ending
barnes noble reviewer sam reader praised
its final line
as quote both a cosmic joke
and one of fiction's darkest examples of
curiosity killing the cat
now the jaunt is set to become a tv show
mrc television which already has
king experience from producing hbo's the
outsider has tapped
david erickson co-creator of fear the
walking dead to develop the story into a
potentially open-ended series
as much as we're wondering how erickson
will expand the premise enough to carry
a full show
we know fans will appreciate how a full
length
jaunt series echoes the story's key
phrase
it's longer than you think stephen
king's novel joyland has a great setting
a down at the heels 70s amusement park
and an equally great
mystery those are two ingredients for a
terrific tv show
so we're happy to say that freeform has
picked it up and a series is in the
works
freeforms carrie burke has shown great
enthusiasm for the show's prospects
she said we are honored to be working
with stephen king
a master storyteller who understands the
importance of culturally embedded tales
that resonate with audiences on a deeply
personal level
that sense of resonance is especially
important for adapting a novel like
joyland
where memories haunt us just as much as
ghosts
if the upcoming series gets that
bittersweet pang right
and knows how to aim for the heart it's
sure to stick with viewers
stephen king originally published the
revelations of becca paulsen
as a short story and subsequently folded
a version of it
into the tommie knockers his novel of
sinister alien influence
once the standalone outer limits episode
it's now entering its next and most
surprising stage of life a series on the
cw
the cw seems like an odd match for king
and it only gets stranger
from there at first you might think the
network is looking for revelations to
fill a horror niche formerly occupied by
the long-running supernatural but
the released concept of the series
suggests they're going for something
wildly different deadline reports the
show's log line
after accidentally shooting herself in
the brain with a nail gun
a pollyanna-ish becca paulston is
recruited by an
overt jesus to be his chosen one in
stopping the apocalypse
in order to save the world becca will
have to prove that our deeply backward
planet earth is redeemable starting with
her quirky midwestern hometown that's
probably enough to outrage stephen king
purists but
we're still curious to see how this kind
of tart offbeat humor blends with king's
original material
stephen king's the boogeyman story is an
eerie
effective blend of psychological
reasoning and that
classic horror concept the monster in
the closet
brian woods and scott beck who are
working to bring a boogeyman movie to
the screen
already have experience tackling this
kind of unease
they co-wrote a quiet place an inventive
and
unsettling horror movie about people who
must constantly
stay quiet in order to avoid a certain
and gory death
they're enthusiastic about their new
horror project and so is stephen king
who has already approved their proposed
script
the boogeyman is taking an appropriately
shambling path towards completion
but we're ready to watch it we'll just
have to barricade our closet doors shut
afterward
stephen king's short novel elevation is
now in the hands of jack
bender who is ready for a change of pace
after working on darker king adaptations
like under the dome mr mercedes and
the outsider one of the things that
attracts him to elevation
is that it's both a classically
enjoyable king read
and a genuinely uplifting tale he told
cinemablend
it's really about how we can all be
better people
and it's a wonderful story it's one of
those little gems and i felt that from
when i first read it
king has already signed off on bender's
script so it's only a matter of time
before we can expect to see this
adaptation
on the big screen thomas jane has
starred in a whole set of stephen king
movies dreamcatcher 1922 and
the mist so when he formed his own
production company with courtney lauren
penn
they announced that his king film streak
would inevitably continue
they're set to adapt from a buick eight
a novel about a group of pennsylvania
state troopers
and the strange and dangerous car they
find themselves guarding over the years
there's no rush on the project jane said
on the podcast
the king cast that recent protests about
police brutality
make him lean towards putting such a cop
heavy story on hold but we do know that
jim mickle is attached to direct
the girl who loved tom gordon is a 1999
novel that
sort of serves as stephen king's attempt
at young adult fiction
it's a scary and gripping story about
trisha mcfarland
a lost little girl who must evade the
god of the lost
a mysterious force stalking her through
the woods she has a tiny bit of
wilderness survival knowledge and
a lot of grit and determination the
novel will be brought to the screen by
director lynn ramsey who has worked on a
wide range of interesting films that
should give her a great
toolkit for tackling the story of a girl
as tough and heroic as trisha mcfarland
fans have waited years for a film
version of the long
walk stephen king's dystopian novel
about a competition where young men
start out on a walk and can't stop or
slow down
breaking the rules gets you shot so they
must walk
or die until only one walker remains
it's a simple premise that has
nonetheless spent a long time alluding
any attempts to put it on the screen but
finally
it just might make it scary stories to
tell on the dark director
andrei overdoll has teamed up with
screenwriter james vanderbilt
known for writing the blockbuster zodiac
to attempt a successful adaptation
overdoll told comingsoon.net this script
was written on spec by james vanderbilt
when he did not even have the rights to
it he just wrote it out of pure
love for the book and in the end
suddenly the rights were open
and he was able to go to king with a
script and say
can we do this that's the kind of
devotion
we like to see and in fact newline
bought the rights so now they can
do it we can't wait until they do
carry is one of stephen king's most
adapted works
and it's set to gain yet another take as
fx has started developing a limited
series
intriguingly fx may be looking to take a
new approach to carry social isolation
collider sources suggest that it's
possible the producers will enlist
either a trans actress an actress of
color
or both to play the titular character if
so
that's an update that will let the
series say new things about how high
school society treats the people who
exist in the margins
and that's something that helps justify
this novel getting another turn in the
spotlight
hbo considers the outsider its adaption
of the stephen king thriller of the same
name to be complete after one season
a limited run series that confines
itself to the events of the novel
but that doesn't necessarily mean the
show is over there are rumors that mrc
the outsiders production company is
shopping the series around to see who
might take it up on a second season
and it's easy to see why someone would
bite the original story of the outsider
is wrapped up but stephen king's novella
if it bleeds features some of the same
characters offering material that a new
season
could easily pull from stephen king also
confirmed with entertainment weekly that
he's seen prospective season 2 scripts
it's all enough to have fans champing at
the bit for more
the third season of mr mercedes will
once again be back with viewers
even though its old home a t network
audience
is now defunct the first two seasons of
the acclaimed stephen king crime series
were previously picked up by peacock
but the third vanished with audiences
shut down however
in 2021 peacock will also acquire what
king
and director jack bender both consider
its quote
best season yet peacock has released a
short trailer for the third season
and with the first two seasons already
available for streaming
this is the perfect time to catch up and
get
hooked while many of the adaptations
we've seen so far
in this list are careening steadily
towards the big screen there are plenty
of others that have been confirmed but
are still in the primordial stages of
development
first off let's take a look at a slew of
shorter pieces that are queued up in the
hollywood assembly line
the little green god of agony a story
about a rich man who hires a kind of
exorcist to rid him of his persistent
unbearable pain
is now in the hands of ian goldberg and
richard name who produce and
write the hit series fear the walking
dead respectively the bone church
one of king's few narrative poems that
depicts the deadly jungle expedition
is set to be produced by chris long
known for his work on the americans
rest stop a brief but brutal tale of a
writer who channels his
darker pseudonym in order to intervene
in an attack happening at a rest stop
has been entrusted to the previously
mentioned alex ross perry
who is also working on a new adaptation
of the dark half
throttle a short story co-written by
king and his son
joe hill is a sort of homage to richard
matheson's
duel which fans might also remember as a
gripping tv movie that happened to be
one of steven spielberg's first projects
hbo max will have the honor of hosting
the adaptation
suffer the little children a short tale
about a volatile relationship
between a teacher and one of her
students has previously been adapted
into a largely unknown short film
now it's been picked up by writer
director sean carter who plans to expand
the piece into a full-length film
he expressed genuine excitement over his
involvement in an interview with sci-fi
wire
it fits right into that classic king
paradigm
a tragically flawed lead character put
into a shockingly
unimaginable scenario it's a tiny peek
into a mythology that i can't wait to
expand into
a full-length movie drunken fireworks
a short story about neighbors exchanging
hostilities via
fireworks displays is also in line for
development with james franco on board
to star
however there's been no news about it
since 2016.
franco has since been accused of sexual
misconduct which he has addressed
publicly
one of the things that i've learned is
that this is a conversation that
obviously needs to be had it goes
without saying that his involvement may
rest on the outcome of
investigations into the matter bbc
reported in february of 2021 that the
lawsuits have been settled in court
so perhaps we'll hear more about this
adaptation sooner than later
furthermore there are a handful of kings
novels that are still in the early
stages of development some of which have
already been adapted in the past
one such work is salem's lot a classic
novel of vampires in a small main town
that has seen two mini-series iterations
horror icon james wan will produce the
upcoming full-length film
and gary dauberman co-writer of both it
films will direct
the novel rose matter which deals with
both domestic violence and rich fantasy
elements is now in the hands of director
of bernstein whose work king
greatly admires netflix is poised to
continue its run of stephen king
adaptations with mr harrigan's phone
a novella found within kings if it
bleeds that features iphone
communication from beyond the grave
numerous producers have signed on to aid
in its development including prolific
and genre-bending ryan murphy
and horror stalwart jason blum johannes
roberts is set to adapt the story within
a story
hearts and atlantis which is part of the
collection of the same name
the movie however will simply be called
hearts needless to say
we're very much intrigued to find out
how his interpretation will compare to
the 2001 adaptation which of course is
loosely based on
low men in yellow coats another novella
within the hearts and atlantis
collection
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stephen king are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you